thank you
[Music]
and welcome back to the most special of
episodes of the careful boys where today
the careful boys have
gotten even closer put it up we got
matching t-shirts oh look how Bloody
your [__] yeah
[Applause]
it's real my bloody hold on mine's
freaking on my boots look at that [__]
he has to take off his pants
oh [__]
we ride
it's the only way that I could show it
I'll watch your coffee
what the [__] male calendar photos
it's the only way the views just went up
I think we got a crop that I think we're
about to lose a monetization on this
video you don't you don't wear shorts
huh blur me out I don't
I I probably I had to go buy those shoes
yeah I'm in the same boat now I gotta
throw away all my shirts I got plasma
coming out
yeah did you guys push it out what does
plasma look like yeah why isn't that
like it's like an X-Men power I think
it's like the extra juice like you only
cut a steak and there's like the extra
juice I think that's plasma because
that's supposed to come out and close
the wounds science
well these are very fresh we got them
done yesterday yeah again big shout out
to my tattoo for coming through the JK
office thank you guys amazing they're so
cool so cool they were so generous event
we got fear everyone t-shirts too that
you're gonna be able to get in October
so these characters are exactly the ones
on our shins so you don't have to get
the tattoo
you can just get the shirt no get the
tattoo if you get the tattoo you get the
shirt for free double shipping I can't
believe it I can't believe that I'm
about to be 40 and my decisions keep
getting dumb right now
so it's all good that we all feel that
way [__] is going on last night I got
back to the hotel and I was like I can't
believe I actually just did that [__]
and then I woke up this morning I'm not
kidding I woke up this morning and I was
like I was like what was I just looking
up I was like oh yeah Harley Davidsons
so stupid
I forgot yeah Dad we're really getting
old Harley Davidson some tattoos man
confusing is that like the default old
man thing to do is I need to all become
bikers and now I I was I was in the Uber
like 20 minutes ago and I was talking to
this guy about Boondock Saints and I
hadn't even seen that movie what you
know I've never seen it oh I was like
that's my favorite movie of all time
dude that's such a good movie it's a
good one yeah
oh my goodness I went home and uh so I
definitely recorded Nina oh yeah she was
like already asleep right I'm like but
she already knew she already knew what
we were doing I sent her a photo while
we were hearing stuff like that so it
wasn't like a big surprise or anything
but she's like asleep I wake her up and
I'm like like recording and then she
like looks at me I put my foot on the
bed
she turns over
and then like five seconds later she's
like what do you want me to say
[Laughter]
[Music]
are are all our wives on the [__]
group chat you they they orchestrated
she was texting Geo last night oh she
was they were texting each other just
saying [__] dumbass emojis to each
other apparently [__] [__] they're
just text me about how dumb everyone is
yeah a bunch of bozos we are Nikki has
been riding me hard ever since 6 45 last
night when I got here what she been
saying she's been cracking my [__]
balls all over oh yeah I had some pretty
good ones yeah she's been killing me and
killing me and then this morning
I get a text and she's like show tat
because because by the time I got back
to the hotel she was asleep and it's
funny because I usually say show butt
and so yeah
she showed I sent her a picture and then
she just like immediately sent it to my
entire family and and added my mom on it
it was like Sherry look what your son
just did I know and then my brother
immediately Google translated it or or
they were like what does it mean and I
said it means I'm the toughest son of a
[__] alive I and then my my little
brother Google translated it and it does
say fear everyone it says I fear nobody
so then my family thinks I'm a [__]
it got fixed on Google it's sometimes
fixed because if you use the Google Live
translate and you point your things it
says fear everyone sometimes it'll say
everyone I fear and then sometimes it'll
say fear no one so then Nikki starts
writing me about how we shouldn't have
done the tattoo during Mercury
retrograde because she knew it's gonna
get all [__] up and now I have a
tattoo that says I'm a tough son of a
[__] and I and I'm not supposed to
supposed to say the office it doesn't
say and you know why it's confused is
because it's backwards yeah yeah so it's
not the right book Google Translates how
how this problem started in the first
place so that's why they haven't so
updated it so we felt better once my
Corners were saying it was accurate like
it says we fear everybody yes but I was
scared shitless about it real Japanese
person reads it they're not gonna see
what Google translate said right but my
brother just thinks I'm a [__] tool
and I think the third character is
actually wrong
probably yeah isn't it I think this line
isn't supposed to exist really it's like
yeah
oh so the character itself is [__] I
think so this one
I don't know this little bars like this
one he's had the same tap for 20 years
what did what did Tiff say to you
the first I come home she's half asleep
right
and she just [__] sleep early yeah
baby's sleeping dog yeah cause you're
not getting sick song yeah they're not
hardcore like us but she just looks at
me and she goes when you came in the
door to just slam it like a man first
yeah
I [__] closed it guess who's home hey
we're watching Sons of Anarchy right now
bro do this world
[Laughter]
she just looked at me with disgust
because I know what that oh man and then
we just went to sleep and then in the
morning yeah I'm talking [__] to her
she's like I'm like what do you think
babe come on looks pretty [__] cool
right and she's like dumb dumb dumb dumb
dumb
dumb dumb so she she said it she thinks
it's stupid yeah yeah and I was like she
goes so you gotta she's like what are
you gonna do for me then I was like what
he's like you got to make this up to me
oh what I was like I was like how did
she use me she's like you gotta do
something for me though whoa
to give him ideas cut that out
and I was like she's right though and I
looked at her and I said I do enough and
then I walked and I give her up
I was like I do enough and I gave her a
hug and I was like you want some coffee
and I made her coffee how did chicks do
that they [__] turn it on you yeah
but I always make her [__]
ing special comment common denominator
here
here y'all are with Latin Latin women
and we're with gingers
Nina's Latin for sure Latin adjacent
yeah they were raped by the Latin
they're Filipinos
oh [__] yeah this is a Filipino table
Filipino wives and then the Latin wives
on this side the Latin wives what did
Geo say well the whole time she thought
it was the [__] most [__] thing
ever dude she called the dumbest man on
Earth tip bro
I'll go through the timeline read it out
dude some of the stuff I can't say
because it was actually sweet stuff
oh no I told her I was like I uh I was
like tell you I'll tell your mom because
my her mom is living at our house right
now and I was like hey tell your mom
that um I was actually looking forward
to seeing her mom tonight but I just
realized that she wasn't gonna be there
because she's back at home so it made me
a little bit sad because I was gonna
miss her so that's like that's [__]
gay sweet [__]
[__] skip it someone's Anarchy
so the first thing is uh this photo that
Anthony sent to the group right that
everything's getting set up so I sent
that to Geo I wrote Anthony just sent me
this and then she writes
Jesus [__] Christ I didn't know she
was so religious you guys are [__]
[__]
the dumbest man on Earth
and then I wrote
that should be our new show name
the dumbest man it's got a ring to it
by the way a lot of people think that
about us yeah yeah expectations are very
low and then I showed her all of our
bear shins because we didn't get it yet
we just got shaved damn you really
updated her yeah she wrote oh my [__]
God I wrote Joe got merch made fear
everyone shirts and I showed her uh
Joe with the shirt on
she goes hahaha blue Crocs
doesn't even respect the shirt and these
are Bart's Crocs too aren't they yeah
because you it was for your character oh
and I just found it and I kept it
there's then I sent a picture of me and
Anthony holding hands while having a
matching tattoo stencil yeah and then
she writes oh my [__] god
um I put uh and then I put Joe about to
get tattooed
everybody loves that you call this the
dumbest man on Earth and she puts a
clown face
and then she doesn't rank much huh no
Geo really doesn't respect Bart at all
and then I sent a picture of Anthony
Orion and Joe already having the tattoo
oh my God and I wrote look how stupid
they look
and then the next one
is Ryan posing like own Bach or
something yeah that's what I was going
for dude I can't wait till the video
comes out of this and I was like Ryan
has this tattoo even before a quest
tattoo
and she goes [__] oh my [__] god
and then I think the final finale is
when I showed my double tattoo
you looking stupid and a bunch of
costumes
dude
fat reaction is even better yeah the
coffin's one was really good
installation dude
the fact that you have double tattoos
both of them right now
[Laughter]
oh my God I'm so happy you got to so
good that's the only reason why I was
down to get it it was a powerful
argument because I was like years you
have to get one too [__] what I think I
got this one in 2013. that's 10 years
2003 10 years ago oh 2003. there it is
nothing but 2003 yeah I think out of
2003 holy [__] that is 20 years oh cool
yeah cause I got it 2003 and then I
remember coming back during like
Christmas leave
so yeah I got it like November it's like
the second you hit 2003 your maturity
plateaued for 20 years or it's really
just Mercury retrograde or the [__]
man I had like my twirky parents fried
you should get that one touched up a lot
of mistakes happen during Mercury
retrograde like get tattoos with a whole
group
I definitely [__] cracked up the
second I showed up and Ryan shaved the
wrong leg oh yeah wait guys I thought we
do left leg we're getting the right leg
right
so he was
he was the right leg dude because I hope
I don't have to get my leg amputated
well because you came with like three
volcano-sized mosquito bites mosquito
bites and I got tatted over all of them
because I'm a [__] hardcore Sons of
Anarchy watching badass
got trucker hats I got 10 trucker hats
coming in the mail I'll say Sam Crow
Nina said what do you want me to say
what did you say did you just go into
bed quietly yeah basically I like put my
[__] tail between my legs and went to
go brush my teeth
you know pick your battles when she gets
a new haircut don't you dare react oh
I don't know that's the equivalent but I
hear your points
don't say a word she's gonna come home
all happy like you notice anything
different you're like you lost weight
just compliment her somewhere else yeah
it's like you notice something different
you're like oh I like your new shirt you
don't even notice anything about me
accurate yeah that's how she is she's
Latin yeah
Latin over here Latin section yeah
Latin adjacents hey if they use pesos
they're Latin that's true that's kind of
true that's a good rule through limos
narrow it sounds hella Latin yeah I
don't care what anybody says yep so who
has the most regret here is it
definitely Nick
said I shouldn't have gone yesterday
that's why he said that's what he texted
us yeah why did you say that huh why did
you say you shouldn't have gone is is
there such thing as tattoo remorse yes
today's video is brought to you by Warby
Parker have you ever looked online and
went shopping and said man look at all
these cool sunglasses but you know what
I don't know if any of these are gonna
look good on my face so I'll just bother
to not buying them have you ever felt
that because I know exactly how that
feels like and so that's why I like
working here with Warby Parker because
because you could do their home try on
kit you can pick the different types of
glasses that you feel fits your face and
then they'll send it to you you put it
on your face and you look at yourself in
a mirror and go sexy and smooth and you
either get to keep it or if you don't
like it you send it right back Warby
Parker offers you everything for happier
eyes you got eyeglasses sunglasses
contacts and even eye exams and you can
shop with them online or in stores
glasses start at 95 including
prescription lenses that's a good deal
try Warby Parker's free home try on
program order five pairs of glasses to
try on at home for free like Joe was
talking about there's no obligation to
buy ships free and even includes a free
prepaid shipping label try five pairs of
glasses at home for free at
warbyparker.com off the Record no not
over here baby but the fact that for
both of your guys's first tattoo and
most people their first time pretty
[__] down it's like so like you know
what this is like my [__] grandma and
there's like some meaningful [__] you
did it for the stupidest reasons you
know what's funny is like I was holding
out for a tattoo for like a meaningful
one but then I realized I realized a
couple years ago that I was like it's
kind of people get tattoos for so many
other reasons it doesn't really matter
anyway so I was like sometimes you're
drunk but also too I was like I'm glad
it's with the boys I think it's kind of
cool you know most people's first
tattoos are way more impulsive and have
way less meaning this has actually way
more meaning this actually has a lot of
meaning yeah
story than anything I could think of but
what is this story because I don't even
know it's based off well look having to
explain it remember it's a rumor you
have to explain your tattoo to somebody
and it's just me and it's just me by
myself that's when it gets a little
shaky right I'm still trying to figure
out how to explain
that it was such an embarrassing tattoo
it was so funny and then we were so low
on faith that this channel would still
be around in the year that we said we'd
get it should we just aim higher that's
really funny is this a a lesson in just
aiming higher no this is this is a
lesson that when you keep your
expectations and life expectations low
it's actually wonderful a year went by
really fast I think it's a lesson to
never make any more promises on this
show yeah yeah let's not we're gonna
keep them do it yeah we will do it we
have to be careful how about that we
have to be careful boys about the
promises but I think I think the the
belly button ring would be cool though
three million no not even three mil just
two points we're getting ahead of
ourselves we got to start one step at a
time where's the tube sock merch
people want temporary tattoos leggings
honestly if we hit 3 million I'm gonna
get a belly button ring with all of you
guys what the heck
just shut the [__] up imagine all of us
in this shirt we cut it on purpose it
was like midriff and then we have a
little race
I need to make more bets that are to our
benefit yeah like hey how about we all
get raises at 2.1 mil there you go Ryan
from here
some more they do piercings too can we
get midriff by the way how did how did
you find them again so uh I've been
going to Andy for a minute I've got a
couple tattoos with him I brought Nina
to him but more importantly I met him
through John Ha uh and John Hall got all
of his sleeves through Andy as well
um so like we I've been like taking all
like the new cats and some of the old
guys who haven't gotten their ink on
their finger to his Huntington Beach
shop for the last couple years just like
constantly bringing fellas through for
Kansas so he's always hitting these up
so is he doing uh at my tattoo in
Alhambra or is he he does it in
Huntington Beach it's always in
Huntington Beach so like every time I go
down there it's such a far drive too
that it's like you know we make a thing
out of it or we're trying to go eat or
whatever you know what I mean those are
like three of the nicest people that we
could have gotten they were so good so
cool yeah shout out to we do not deserve
them Sonny and to man man it's [__]
funny he's one of the funniest people
I've ever met hey before you got here
man was like Hey I know Bart from before
like by he said his wife went to school
he was in the same class sat next to you
and we were like what was Bart like in
school and he said oh like nerdy
he just said nerd yeah and we were like
what and then when I told him to repeat
it when you got here he was like oh cool
buff strong
had some stomach he's the best he's the
funniest one because it's like all quiet
or whatever and it's like uh what do you
say it was like um you're talking about
the the tattoo gun he's like you should
put it in your butt
and then the wrong time what's the
tattoo Karen no sex for 10 years
they're talking about like safely
disposing of the used needles he's like
we go to a children's playground spread
it all over this he's so [__] they
were great man it is delivery so like
out of nowhere
throws it away Nick what was your true
pain level during the tattoo honestly it
was it was unlike anything I've ever
experienced so I was like oh [__] it's
weird huh it's a weird feeling it's like
a burning it hurts the most when it was
on like muscle it felt like that's what
I was like it just felt like raw you
know what I mean like someone's digging
into a wound a little bit but um there
were definitely Parts where the shading
felt less painful the outline initially
felt yeah it was painful and then when
he did the [__] the traditional
Japanese well yeah dude get into that
you got the traditional test I know
exactly what you mean now
because it's less frequent so but like
you still feel the Pricks but it's like
not as bad it looks like you're getting
a shot it's pain like this versus pain
like this
you know what I'm talking about yeah
yeah man [__] you guys I was getting my
mosquito bites tattooed did that hurt
you guys are talking about [__] pain
and [__] you said you loved it because
it was like it was It was kind of nice
actually because it was like getting
scratch the whole time but it was like
man when she was really digging in there
for to like like on like the volcano
part of it it was like wow dude this is
pretty interesting sensation yeah whoa
oh yeah my teeth were rattling the whole
time ago but I felt bad because Steve
would say these stupid jokes and it
would make me laugh and I hear Andy goes
whoa whoa whoa whoa and I'm like [__]
[__] I hate doing that like I hate being
that because I was trying not to shake
the table because my laugh like goes
like this and then he [__] came by
was filming me and he goes oh colored
hair huh and then because she had like
pink hair and he goes Ryan Taylor your
views on people with with colored hair
typically yeah what are your views and I
was like what the [__]
and then also too another shout out to
[__] Anthony this guy's grabbing my
nut sack playing with my shorts you
definitely elevated that I was just I
was just doing a little peek for the
viewers you were being too tempted you
were taking some photos bro yeah I was
uh I was drunk and I was trying and I
was just shoveling your [__] feet for
like three years and he switched angles
that went right behind your ear I was
doing dude he was doing the full like
Nick between Nick's legs up to Nick's
nose that was that was his that was me
that was Ryan we was getting badges dude
we're suckers to money no but people
gave hella badges when they were we were
showing up your shorts
so maybe we should cut you in on that
one yeah dude actually I would love 22
dollars
made right about yeah I think we made
like a hundred bucks or something that's
pretty sick
so sick let's go around real quick and
just talk about real quickly what the
tattoo means to us in in true terms and
true terms okay
Nick go ahead no I can't start dude
I can't start you should start you know
that you never got one before so it has
the most means yeah new guys first
meeting is it's learning how to deal
with regret in a healthy way
[Laughter]
thank you Nick thank you thank you
bark
wait no I just say late because you have
two you should go less
I think mine is the lesson I learned
is mistakes are funnier when you do it
twice
I'm still processing that I did this
yeah same that's fair yeah because you
haven't even had one long in 20 plus
years wow or something like that we're
still regretting this and you weren't
even planning on probably getting any
more for the rest of your life and then
randomly this thing pops up because of a
rumor
I honestly don't even know how it was
done but I was laughing because the I
the the real reason why I wanted to get
it is because I wanted to see Bart with
two
and since I was like it's a very jealous
thing to do because this is because you
guys remember when I brought it up I was
like oh yeah we're all gonna get this
matching tattoo but Bart has to do it
too so his other leg and then we were
dying laughing right and if I was like
yeah and I was like oh we're doing this
and then Anthony was like I'm gonna
schedule this and I'm like holy [__]
Bart's gonna have to do on his leg it's
honestly Anthony's fault what blame
Anthony dude Ryan's a guy who's
perpetuating on social media yeah I did
okay but you set the appointment I gotta
put gas on a [__] Ember I think the
funniest part about it though is it like
solidifies the careful boys but at the
same time the stupidest way possible
yeah right and we don't none of us know
how it even happened it's just sort of
organically stop talking about that like
I don't know how who brought it up who
said yes
we all said yes yeah but I remember but
I think we always say yes yeah that's
true I don't remember the Catalyst at
all like which was the who was it yeah
who was the who's on that the Bad Brad
idea we should get a matching tattoo I
don't know I mean the JK viewers
definitely know if you guys remember put
in the comments who started the whole
place the blame
to me I think I I love how organically
and naturally we got to the stupid ass
position yeah that's pretty cool I
appreciate the comedic value of it a ton
and I think like the idea of getting a
tattoo with other people was always
pretty stupid to me it's like the
dumbest thing that people do but then or
like to even get something that's
visible like that's cool when you get
like a little something behind your ear
or whatever on my upside but then this
is so visible and so dumb and is so
gonna be asked about yeah I could I love
the answer for it yeah because it is the
official answer the official answer is
that weird Bart tell us a a terrible
story about a regrettable like stupid
tattoo and now we all share in that and
have extended the story I love that we
got it too I love that yeah and I think
the the best part about the story is
it's really like a Campfire story like
it'll you have to deep like go through
the details of why Bart even got it in
the displays and how he [__] up right
and then the the fast forward of like
it's a Scorsese film dude also my my
favorite my absolutely it's his worst
movie
my favorite thing is that we we told the
JK audience we were gonna do it and we
[__] did it yeah that's pretty good
and that's not well they reminded us
after we hit two mil and I was like I
don't even remember it had nothing to do
with two mil by the way had nothing to
do no it was about survival which is the
sad part there's so many creators that
say whatever the [__] and then they just
forget about it but like we actually
like came through with it and I think
that's that's a big thing that the
audience came through for us in the past
year and it's like for us to do this is
like really solidifying like no we
really do hear what people say and we
hold ourselves accountable for that [__]
and then they find another podcast
tomorrow and just leave yeah they just
leave
yeah
I think it's a Doper minor too but we
worked hard for this past year I think
too and what we built together I [__]
love this place and I wouldn't have a
tattoo with anybody else I love you guys
yeah Steve this is awesome oh I wish I
said something sweet
that's why I want you to go first
because it was gonna be [__]
I think about relationships is a good
word uh like Ryan said you know um just
even seeing people like our fans on the
live or people that have been tagging us
after the fact and just having this
newfound respect for us because we
actually did it like the word respect
yeah just like a hearty heart I think
that's the word the respect
my face Emojis all the way up until the
tattooing I thought this was like the
most hilarious story yeah but then after
the fact like actually thinking about it
and like even one moment just sitting on
the couch and Ryan looking at me like
dude we [__] did this and just like
yeah randomly bonding in these moments
like as [__] cheesy as this is
I talked about this like like the idea
of getting married to Nina it's like
you're already in like a nine-year
relationship and then getting married
how does that change it it's like you
didn't know that it could elevate it so
much even though oh yeah that much or
even like
one like Mike's Dad when Mike's dad got
lost and we went to go try and [__]
find him and stuff it's like I didn't
know after all like 20 years of being
best friends with Mike that we would get
bonded even closer this is like an
unexpected way that I would like I
didn't know our relationship could get
that much higher and crazier and now I
feel like bonded to y'all for life so I
think that's just one we're married now
legit I'm married to five other men dude
yeah that's kind of true well man maybe
that's why our wives don't like it that
much yeah because we're all bonded
together now we're just the original
best friend shows up he goes can I join
guys or would you kick his [__] ass
beat the [__]
oh yeah there's gonna be a whole episode
about this so the entire uh tattoo
process everything there's a whole JK
episode that's gonna come out probably
in the first of next October first week
of October and that's the same time that
these shirts were released where you can
finally buy them so uh please support us
by buying one of these shirts quick
update my mom says my eyes are clearer
now good try trying to trick me it's
fake shut up
for 30 years I [__] with this woman